get into an issue
of concern to just about everybody out
there and that is the high cost of
living this year inflation soared to
levels not seen in more than 40 years
and though last month the overall rate
seemed to slow a bit grocery prices have
continued their climb they have risen
every month this year up more than 13
since last summer alone and that is
straining food budgets and leading some
to wonder what is driving the price
hikes and where is all your grocery
money going anyway we decided to find
out or try to find out anyway by
following the price of a good old
american staple a gallon of milk
there's one word that can sum up a trip
to the grocery store these days
obnoxious
the prices yes inside the dnd market in
delhi in southeastern pennsylvania just
about everything is costing more and
that's most certainly true down aisle
one in the dairy section prices are up
for whole milk two percent fat free
everything is all of it everything
shalish patel is the owner so how much
more does a gallon of milk here cost
today than last year almost close to
like a
dollar
in fact nationwide the average price of
a gallon of milk jumped almost a dollar
since the start of the pandemic it's
enough to make you wonder where your
extra dollar is headed
and whether there might be someone
somewhere who's getting a dollar richer
you're not making an extra dollar no i'm
not making any extra ones the extra
dollar he's taking in he says goes
straight to the wholesaler and
eventually to places like this when an
everyday american buys milk wherever
they are in the country and they're
paying a dollar more than they were a
year and a half ago well if it wasn't
for that then a lot more farmers would
be going out of business
wendell gaiman is a third generation
farmer raising cows here on marwell
dairy farm less than an hour from the
dnd market
[Music]
and while he's most definitely selling
the cow's milk for more than he was
he's also pouring that extra money away
so wendell this is the stuff that's
costing more this is the stuff that's
costing more all because of a giant
increase in the price of feed where was
it before
prices started rising and where is it
today i think it was about uh
three thousand dollars a month and then
it's now close to forty five hundred or
five five thousand wow
just to buy the feed wow
that means your extra dollar is going to
cover his rising costs so what you're
saying is it it's not going to get
wendell and every other dairy farmer a
better pickup truck and a bigger tv no
i wish but that's not how it works
which brought us to our next stop where
your extra dollar eventually goes right
into the register of a shop
like this one so wendell says he's
paying more for feed mm-hmm is that true
that's very true
kevin goulden is co-owner
of ole valley feed you've got corn going
up
and those are your ingredients pretty
much to make feed using these charts and
tables golden explained to us that your
extra dollar doesn't stay with him
either when you're looking for somebody
to blame for the higher price where do
you point the finger world economics
world economic oh yeah because this is a
global market in what we do but world
economics is kind of an unsatisfying
boogie man here right you know i can't
call him on the phone and complain i
can't write an angry letter no one to
complain to
and he's absolutely right
inflation is such a complicated topic
it's one that economists truly do not
understand all that well gina's miali
covers inflation for the new york times
where does it really begin who's the
first person to raise the price i think
it is so difficult to talk about this
because inflation is no individual
person's fault right the government did
a lot of stimulus during the pandemic
and that helped to push up consumer
demand which is part of the inflation
story people had more money and they
could demand more things because they
had the cash and that helped to push
inflation up initially i think we can
absolutely say that corporations
expanded their profit margins during
this period you know corporations saw
that their costs were increasing
increase their prices but increase their
prices by more than they necessarily
needed to just to cover those costs
however that is kind of how capitalism
works but when it comes to something as
seemingly simple and straightforward as
a gallon of milk the story of your extra
dollar only gets more complicated so we
are starting to see some improvement in
the ports involving long-term impacts
from production and delivery issues
and volatile fuel prices affecting way
more than just milk early in the
pandemic everybody wanted a new couch or
a new living room set they ordered those
and
the shipping routes that we all use
globally to transport our goods got
really clogged up as that happened the
cost of transporting anything started to
really skyrocket it became expensive to
transport feed or grain or you know
whatever you need to make a farm operate
which ends up making the milk that
you're buying today a year and a half
later a lot more expensive because at
every sort of
link in this chain we've seen prices
going up and that just echoes through
the supply chain
i tried i really tried to find the one
bad guy i mean this so i want to do this
story because uh people are going to be
voting uh in less than a hundred days
right they're gonna blame someone for
inflation everyone's got a boogeyman
some claim uh the biden administration
and stimulus some blame russia some
blame corporate greed some blame
covetous
disruptions and the answer is all of it
yeah to some extent and also none of it
it's all combined into one thing so
kind of vote your partisan opinion
because even economists can't sort it
out no who's making that dollar yeah
everybody and nobody it's sort of like
the ouija board this is the metaphor
i've come to right like the ouija board
everyone's got their hand and they're
moving it around and it's making
different letters and it's the spirit
world it's everybody's pressure and
nobody's pressure that's the answer to
what's driving up costs there is no
person making that extra dollar it's
everybody and yet nobody at the same
time it's so frustrating i feel like i'm
following the sell signal across a patio
and i'm like i can't see it but i'm
walking for it where is it well there's
so many different types of inflation
that can happen too and as you said it's
almost like a convergence of all of them
at once which is unfortunate it's deeply
unsatisfying but getting better
uh maybe maybe
they can't predict because they don't
even know what caused it that's that's
part of gas prices that's one piece of
it right that's the energy is just one
part of this i don't know politicians
will make claims people are going to try
to sort it out it's a guess that's the
bottom line